séance photo pour unis le mieux une
jeune femme de 26 ans ces clichés se
retrouveront sur son profil instagram
qui compte plus de 30 mille abonnés au
niveau des filles rondes j'ai comme été
une des premières à vraiment faire comme
bon temps mauvais temps sur internet
dont on partage un petit moment de
confiance en soi
qu'est ce qui t'a large carte et cela
c'est normal de ses mines il est le
mieux est ce qu'on appelle une influence
euse les influenceurs ont un large
auditoire sur les réseaux sociaux
parfois il son porte parole de
l'entreprise et vantent leurs produits à
d'autres moments il a fléchi simplement
ce qu'ils aiment y lit elle
l'agent tout faire la promotion d'un
corps en santé 75 % de ce qui est
socialement collecte comme le corps très
mince trop gras très présent mais je
pense que l'autre 1 5% qui plus difficle
mois défi qui brille vraiment comme le
genre de modèle correct il y en a de
plus en plus que c'est ce qu'ils font en
effet de plus en plus de femmes rondes
des blogueuses des mannequins au québec
et partout dans le monde tente de
redéfinir les standards de beauté sur
les médias sociaux et didier l'humilie
jessica et vanessa ont cet objectif en
commun quand je te donnerai pas de
modèle fait que je regarde la télévision
puis je voyais personne qui me
ressemblait donc avec le temps je me
suis dit je veux créer ce pour la
génération des plus jeunes cette année
vont toujours la même salutation au
soleil à hyogo des filles en bikini sur
la plage du soleil donc été la recrue
doit offrir une image et de nombreuses
études démontrent que les réseaux
sociaux peuvent nuire à les styles de
soi si influent ce sont des exemples à
suivre
selon ces petits colloque spécialisé
dans les problèmes d'image corporelle
c'est s'assumer dans notre authenticité
dans notre unicité et ça c'est un
message c'est dommage mais un peu
nouveau ces personnes là qui ont les
tribunes ils y ont cette chance là en
fait de pouvoir promouvoir en un message
complètement à l'opposé de la pression
qu'on ressent
j'ai commencé à mieux me sentir dans mon
corps pour mieux accepter quand j'en ai
vu d'autres comme moi qui reflétait
cette image de confiance d'acceptation
c'est important devant tous les types de
femmes dans le fond pour que parce que
les idées femme drôle et on un puits
sont belles mais on y voit très
que veut promouvoir sur l'obésité nous
autres en vue de promouvoir le fait
d'être bien dans sa peau au québec
un adolescent sur deux n'aime pas son
corps il y le mieux leur lance ce
message tout le pack on perd à focus et
sur notre image corporelle que ce soit
construite négatif il ya d'autres choses
qui se passent dans ce temps là c'est là
que la vie commence ici marie laurence
de l'émirat du canada montréal